[Music]
ah
a pleasure to meet you uh sean thank you
for uh giving us your time today i
appreciate it my pleasure appreciate you
having me slightly weird for me because
i as with many people
i just grew up watching you fly through
the air and entertain millions of us i
think one of my first wrestling memories
was you on top of a ladder
against scott hall yes sir yeah uh what
a match that was to be introduced to
wrestling uh you sort of set the bar too
high if anything for me
yeah well thank you very much yeah well
that's i i'll say this that's uh
certainly one a lot of people remember
the irony is i don't think scott and i
had any idea at the time
that it would
be as big and kind of
i don't know uh
memorable and iconic uh we had done
as i've told people on many occasions we
had done numerous ladder matches uh
strangely enough um and so for us it was
uh it was kind of another another day at
the office they were uh they wanted to
give it a try at wrestlemania and
sort of see if it was something that um
i know they felt would stick and clearly
you know all the all these years later
uh it stuck pretty well i mean that
seemed to be a bit of a
theme with your career
you know the uh the hell in the cell
against the undertaker often viewed as
uh
the the one that everyone tries to live
up to and same with the ladder match
what is it like being held as the golden
standard to an industry like that first
of all i mean it's incredibly flattering
and i don't know i think i don't know i
i don't know that it's the golden
standard but i i do know that i was
always honored that you know i was kind
of the guinea pig if we wanted to try to
find
i don't know if something worked i liked
taking risks i i enjoyed taking chances
and seeing if i could
do something that maybe everyone else
hadn't done yet um and so
uh i was fortunate enough to one have
that kind of attitude and then also have
a i guess a company that didn't mind
putting me putting me out there and
taking risks in some of these matches um
so again as i look back obviously i'm
very proud of a lot of them at the time
um you know you're just so anxious and
excited to try anything you know and and
as as i'm sure you know uh you know when
you're younger you feel like you're 10
feet tall and bulletproof as you can do
you know i mean that's you can do
anything that's certainly the way i felt
at the time and uh obviously again now
that i'm older and more mature i'm i'm
very proud to look back on uh the body
of work that i that i did
yeah one of the things that seems that
people loved about working with you i
viewed the undertaker recently and
people talk about how you
would as they say sell for for them and
and to help make the other guy
look amazing what was it about doing
sort of that kind of acting performance
that
you managed to get a hold of in your
mind and be able to bring that to life
in the ring
it's funny because uh at six months in
the wrestling business um
i was in mid-south and i had been there
for a while and bill watts was you know
finishing me up
and he was getting me started helping me
to get started in kansas city and he
said sean he said
he said look you've got a lot of ability
a lot of talent i think you can do
something in this business you've
learned as much as you can learn here
you've learned to take a hell of an ass
kicking and uh he said
he said if you're not careful
you'll end up taking one for the rest of
your career um
and what he meant by that is you need to
go somewhere else there's an art
to also learning how to win and to get
over as we say
um
but in the from the time that i broke
into it you know as the
business evolved and grew thankfully
enough i had the ability to get beat up
well i guess and that turned out to be
something that i could use to my
advantage as what people call selling
it's one of the things that i did well
as both a good guy and a bad guy
thankfully i was able to
make a wonderful living out of being
able to get get beat up well essentially
honestly this is is what it is yes i had
some uh i had some very good exciting
offensive moves that i could do but i
think
what people are most most associated
with sean michaels was
his ability to get beat up is his
selling and taking bumps as we say and
that's something that i i really enjoy
doing that too for what it's worth i i i
that was never something that seemed
like a lot of work to me and the more
that i did it the more people seemed to
enjoy the matches and so for me it was
all a very natural um i don't know a
natural evolution for me and thankfully
uh
it made everybody look good it you know
so that sort of
made people enjoy working with me
whether they liked me personally or not
they knew they could have good matches
with me um and thankfully that always
takes precedence over anything else the
thing about um
watching your matches that really that
grabbed me was the way the matches would
flip-flop where you'd think it was going
one way then it would go the other way
then it would go and it was so
believable and that was
key to keeping people's attention for
long periods of time i'm thinking of
like
the iron man match you did with brett
for example at wrestlemania 12 i think
it was and uh watching you coming from
the skies created like just such a
moment and
i know undertaker's uh kind of got mr
wrestlemania but you definitely pushed
him for that when when you mention about
uh your personality and whether people
like you personally or not
uh what is it like looking back
at those younger years for you because
obviously
a lot of people said a lot of things
about how you behaved in the backstage
because you were the superstar and now
you're in a man who's you know wise you
look back at that what is it like
looking back at that
well look obviously you know i'm i'm i
would love to be
to be able to change a lot of it
obviously
um but i always tell people so i i don't
know
if i'd have gotten where i got to or had
the success that i had if i didn't go
about it that way and again obviously
um
you know we'll never know but uh i think
again i i i'm always kind of remiss to
want to change anything for fear i
wouldn't be where i'm at now which i i
totally love so look i would love to
have been able to
have handled myself more maturely more
professionally um
but
and and still been able to have all the
talent of the ability but i know i'm not
sure if i'da had the confidence and the
drive
and the ambition that i had in that ring
night after night day after day year
after year
if i didn't have that same attitude i
was very
uh
i was angry but i was also i really
wanted to make a point and
so i don't know i don't know if i'd if i
had done it another way i don't know
that i'd have driven that home as much
as i would have liked to so
um it's i don't know if it makes sense
but it's kind of uh you know
you know
sure i would have loved to have changed
it but
that might have changed everything um
and i wouldn't want that
yeah uh well it's ironic because i've
just interviewed
logan paul earlier today who made his
debut
in at wrestlemania and similarly
if you take that out of a personality
that young youthful i can do anything
don't tell me what i can't do
you just don't get the same output
um and i was wondering what you thought
of his his debut because a lot of people
were fairly impressed by it
absolutely and i i was as well and
that's something that
i'm glad you brought it up because again
you know that was
look it's always
a question i know to people when we
bring in against celebrities from the
outside
and now i will say
i think the celebrities really make a
really you know
big effort to make sure that they adjust
to our our sport well
but he did a fantastic job i i know i
will say this i wasn't that surprised by
it because again if you again if you've
watched him in boxing and almost
everything he does
he jumps into it you know a full bore
you know i mean he's one percent
committed to to everything he does so i
wasn't surprised by it but at the same
time he really did do a fantastic job um
and and again
what we do isn't easy uh by any stretch
and
uh especially if you're going to do it
just once again i always found
you know that you know again people
would always ask me that's why you know
taker and i always i was always
impressed with the way he would he'd go
a year off and come back to
wrestlemanias and people would ask me
like why don't you do that right he's
just like no way that's harder to me you
know what i mean i'm better
doing it more consistently um but to
just have to
step away from it and get back into it
that takes a lot of commitment and for
somebody that's never done it and then
to jump in and to jump in all the way
and commit to it like he did again i i
admire that and i think you did a great
job
as with everyone who interviews you i
have to bring up the the screw job uh
it's just part of your your life and it
was a fascinating time in wrestling
where wrestling became
more real than ever
and obviously for those who don't know
you were a part of a match that was
supposed to end one way and then
was changed to benefit the company
because the other star bret hart was
leaving and you were involved in the
submission hold where obviously got
called uh off now
i was wondering in that time that you
were sworn to secrecy about your
knowledge of this
what was it like sort of having to
go about the back room
and
lie to all of those other wrestlers and
keep this sort of bond that you'd been
sworn to secret
yeah that's the part that sucked the
most yeah to be very honest
especially especially
at that time um
i'd felt so much better being able to
say yes i knew you know um
that honestly um
in the long run became the hardest and
the biggest burden because again
what we have in there again no matter
what you
may feel about somebody personally
there's the trust there there's a trust
there um that we have with one another
every night that we go out there you
know
uh taking care of each other taking care
of each other's bodies
and i knew that was obviously gonna
damage um
that and i will say that there might
have been a lot of people that disliked
me but there wasn't anybody that did not
enjoy being in the ring with me
um and that honestly as i told people on
many occasions that was the hardest part
honestly is um
losing what i felt like would be that
trust um
with the other guys yeah and look i'll
say this i i think obviously over time
it weighed on me more and more um
but and of course vince did everything
he could you know to try to take as much
of that responsibility but
how mad is anybody going to get at him
right you know so i i i'm the easy guy
so honestly for me that was the hardest
issue all together which was not being
able to come clean about it it seemed
like you had this
party boy
you know
undeniable superstar attitude and it did
seem to sort of spiral in in like you
became your own worst enemy in some
regards
and eventually you had this sort of
wake-up call where you decided to become
a very different person and that that's
very rare to yeah i interview a lot of
people and it's very rare someone will
do such a 180 and become so different at
a middle point of their life and that
takes a lot of real soul-searching and i
was just wondering sort of what brought
that on for you first of all it's uh you
know i will say i think the genesis of
all of it would be obviously meeting
who's you know the woman who's now my
wife um
um she was sort of the beginning of it
uh i look
she was the first time that i
really uh
if i'm being honest loved anything more
than
either myself or the wrestling business
uh and it was the first time for me i
experienced real love and then of course
we had
you know uh a child and you know and
when
first found out that she was pregnant it
now things
it was the first time that something was
bigger than myself to be perfectly
honest um
and
the idea of
this
human being this little human being
turning out like me
and uh it scared me to death to be
perfect to be perfectly honest um
and that honestly is what did it it was
just something that that uh and again i
mean i don't want to meet anybody over
there with my bible and go too far into
my faith but obviously that had a great
deal to do with it but that honestly is
all sort of the same thing
believing and having something bigger
than myself and that was to me it was
just
about you know really
full unconditional love for something
that i've never had before and this
person being 100 dependent on if he was
going to turn out to be any
type of
redeeming
man
he was probably going to look at his dad
first and it just made me
uh look in the mirror and as you say do
a lot of soul-searching and it is not
fun
it's a
an incredibly humbling uh
thing to go through uh when you realize
that you start to pick yourself apart
and look at the things you can improve
on uh the list was uh
long to say the least you know credit do
you for being a man enough to do that it
takes a lot of effort and um you've
really stuck to it uh that that's quite
clear because i remember when you first
came back to wrestling it's a few people
like is this an act like people didn't
really know how to take you from all the
interviews i've watched uh one of the
things that sort of built up that
character that people had an idea about
you was being a part of the clique and
this is a group of wrestlers who
were kind of notorious or really the bad
boys of wrestling who seemed to have a a
hold on wrestling in two different
organizations but
the irony was is that your sort of
little brother in all of that was triple
h and
my meeting and most wrestling fans
meeting of triple h where we really
became familiar with him was as your
sort of right-hand man
if i had said to you back then you know
one day this guy is going to be the most
powerful man in wrestling
how would you have took that i don't
know i'd have said the most powerful man
wrestling is driving me down the road
and taking it
and taking me up to my uh hotel room
when i'm i'm half out of it um yeah yeah
no again it really has been uh
you know an amazing journey um to say
the least uh and it is
look we we were real life friends um and
obviously he did you know
i don't know he showed me the ultimate
friendship by again
being there for me when i was not you
know at my best and
um
because of that there's just been a
you know a i don't know a lifelong
devotion
to our friendship with one another and
um and that's why even now that again
me taking on
what i'm doing now is is doing my best
to you know to pay him back for
everything that he did for me you know i
mean when i needed it and
and that's me doing everything that i
can while he needs it um
and that's the process we're in now but
again no i would have never
look uh
when i left with my back injury
it was one way and then i came back and
you know he's you know i'm now
one of the groomsmen at his wedding with
uh you know
stephanie mcmahon yeah and then of
course his you know his rise to as you
say being one of the most powerful men
yeah in in the business all together and
uh
but they're still we're still
you know he's still honored to me you
know you know all he's you know he's
we're still friends there's there's an
aspect of that where
i can at least be
that real aspect of his life that
nobody else
really knows about and that's the one
thing that myself and kevin and kid
you know
can at least share with him on the side
that not many other people can and most
importantly that he can't i think that's
the biggest thing for me is um is being
a refuge for him
away from uh ironically enough uh the
wwe from the wrestling business as a
whole yeah so when you talk about your
role now helping him it's it's it's
building the nxt a brand and and
bringing through the new wave of
wrestlers and passing down that
knowledge and hopefully helping him
create future superstars uh what is it
like to be a teacher now because i
remember you being taught
i remember seeing videos of you being
taught in the run-up to wrestlemania 12
from your old teacher yeah well look um
it's it's gone it's evolved you know uh
a lot even in the time that i've been
here i when i first came here
to nxt it was just to in a coaching role
and it was mostly just to again to be
with a certain group of guys once they
felt like they got to a certain level
um and help them i don't know better
understand
storyline and psychology and again
helping them understand that the moves
were the moves but they could really
just play a backdrop to a bigger part of
a story um
and
then it slowly evolved into
you know um taking over nxt uk
and then obviously at one point uh you
know writing
and
producing
nxt and then writing producing nxt uk
and then now sort of what it's
culminated into now which is again for
the most part
uh
running
running both brands uh obviously with a
a great team that he put in place
around me um and having
less time so to speak to coach
individually
but try to
grow both brands in a way that again
does what we're supposed to do here
which is prepare
the nxt superstars to be the wwe
superstars of tomorrow and on into the
future how receptive is um triple h 2
feedback from you because i feel like
there's so much control that he has now
over the brand and and a lot of people
are going to have so many different
opinions of whether he should they go
zag and obviously he's going to trust
you a lot do you have a lot of
conversations like that are you too
focused on what you're doing often to
just
let him get on with it
when he was when he was here uh on a
regular basis um i certainly always we
had a great deal of back and forth um
and i think again i feel like he always
knew that he would get the truth from me
um and that's one of the things that
certainly now in being in this position
you begin to understand that you may not
always be getting the cold hard truth
you might be getting what people think
you want to hear
and you having to discern
what's best and that's one of the things
i think that he's
taught me you know i guess the most is
that there are times again that i can
lean on him and ask him something i know
he'll give me the best answer um and i
know it'll be the truth and and and
again whether it's good or it's bad she
knows you can tell me that it's better
overall for both my growth and the
growth of the brand
um i like to think that's what i gave
him at the same time
the one thing that i will say is that
i don't and i'm continuing to learn i
don't have the vast knowledge uh that he
has because he's
had you know like he said it's like sean
i've had a decade head start on you you
know i mean he said it's you know yeah
um it's one of those things that you
know i have almost forgotten
how long he's actually been doing this
and doing it at a high level
and that's one of the things that i find
myself
appreciating more and more
is again the depth of knowledge and
innovation that he has
from a production standpoint and those
are
some of the things that i hope to
obviously glean information from him
throughout the years as we continue to
go forward and lists
as um somewhat might have seen that it
was it was sad to say that he sort of
had retirement in-ring retirement forced
on him
in the last year
uh a lot of people feel like you went
out the perfect way you know the perfect
match everything was amazing about your
final goal but he didn't he wasn't so
lucky how do you think he's
gonna cope with not being able to
scratch that itch mentally
well i'll say this i
from all i can tell
that everything for him has been put
into perspective and and
one way or another i believe
that's one of the greatest lessons of
life it will teach you one way or
another
um about perspective it's just up to you
the individual to receive it um
and he has done both and i think he
understands that
um the career that he had is second to
none there's so much to be proud of
there is a future
um
from a business standpoint of so much
more to fulfill um that has nothing to
do with the ring
and the most important i think again is
his family i think he's understood the
balance that needs to be there and that
when everything is said and done you
know
uh
you know those those daughters of his
and his wife that's
the most important thing in his life
i think he's having the time to be able
to enjoy that as he should
um
and and look i i think when for all of
us when you
get that realization that it finally
sinks in
yes this job very important to to all of
us
but
it is still a job when it's said and
done
it's still something that really
is not based
and grounded in reality and family is
and so when it comes
again as i like to say when it comes to
nut cutting time reality always takes
precedence
i like it um and obviously mentioning uh
him and the click uh very sad to see
that we lost scott hall in the last year
um how did you guys as a friendship
group sort of uh deal with that and
cope together
just that together um you know i i
so it's one thing you kind of always
wonder
um
in the years followed
will it stick was it all as special as
you thought it was and when it and when
something like this happens
to find out that
that it all is
and that it's
still
i don't know
we're still that group of guys that
bonded
so well together
on the road in this line of work
together and
20 plus years later
we can still come together and it's
still
i don't know there yes there was an
unbelievable sadness there
but
the overwhelming joy of all of us
understanding and appreciating and
valuing the friendship that we have and
seeing how important it was
i think that was the most positive thing
in all of this for us it was sad and
tragic to lose scott
um but i can just say for me personally
i don't know it was
it was so great to find out that i don't
know that we were all still gonna be
there
when
uh
it's coming to the end
and uh
i don't know i don't think you can ask
for much more of that um again for all
of us to be able to be there
with each other be able to say goodbye
and and
i don't know uh and then to be together
to to mourn and to comfort one another
afterwards
that's pretty special and i think that's
the best you can get when it comes
uh to the finality of death wrestling is
a pretty brutal industry or at least it
has been
uh with so much sadness for a lot of you
guys you know i do feel for you because
so many close friends seem to have been
lost by you guys when i talk to one of
you i see that ric flair is actually
coming out of retirement for one last
match
i bet you that raised a few eyebrows
like what is it like to see that when
he's doing his little practice drills
and he's putting this social media
videos out
well so i i've uh
i guess it's one good thing about my
schedule i've been so busy i just know
of him doing that and
um and so look i think those of us that
that know the nature are are always i
don't know kind of tickled with that you
know it's it's never over for the niche
and so
look that's one of the things that makes
him who he is yeah um
we want i want rick to be happy and and
getting in the ring one more time um
again especially if you know rick knows
if he can do it or not rick knows if
he's uh healthy enough and if it's
something that brings him joy brings him
contentment
i wish him the best obviously always
want him to be careful
um but i think
when it comes to being on that ring that
might be where he's most comfortable and
that's where he finds the most amount of
joy and if that's the case
um and he can do it and stay healthy and
happy uh i'm i'm always going to support
him in that yeah i mean
that's the thing with you when i look
over your career there was just so many
instrumental moments that you played in
uh you were the king maker for steve
austin you you had some of the biggest
and best matches with the undertaker you
retired uh ric flair and
i was talking with my friends before
about how many moments you had it's
crazy but the ric flair one specifically
that moment where you look at him and
say you know i'm sorry i love you
what made you say that before you did
that out of interest
because it was real for me you know he
was my guy um
and
look and honestly and even at that time
you know
at that time
i'm aware
because what you just said i've had the
opportunity to think about that i've
been a part of so many wonderful things
and big moments
in this business and especially at the
time of that match the whole second half
of my career from 2002 on
every time i got in the ring i
understood that that it was a second
chance and that i had already done all
these amazing things and here i was
getting to do it again so every time i
was in there
it was from a place of such thankfulness
and all of those thoughts that you just
talked about were always in my head and
now i'm in there with the guy
that when i was 15 i used to watch on
television and again you would talk
about i'm gonna do that someday but
never knowing if it's real and now it is
and so
it was all genuine it is all real that's
the great thing
about this job it's what still keeps me
doing it now um
is that there's a romance there that
goes on um
even though it is everything you said it
can be brutal it can be rough um you
know
it will hit below the belt um a lot of
times
but there's still
you know again a love and a romance
there
that has never faded um and partly
because
of that guy and also now for me because
of all of those memories and it's hard
not to
i don't know again i'll say this i'm i'm
married to a woman and have two children
that have all grown with me and they go
they understand
dad has two loves in his life it's us
and the wrestling business and
they share me with it
uh-huh
and um
and looking back at
another wrestler who you had like an
amazing rivalry with bret hart you and
brett hart are like some sort of uh it's
like star wars harry potter sort of like
good and evil like that was what it was
back then it one needed the other
and you just like pushed each other to
the limit and it was such a great
rivalry and obviously it was based on
truth that there was real genuine bad
blood at times and bitter you're wanting
to outdo each other i was wondering if
you've ever had a conversation now as a
as older guys you know where you really
had a heart a heart of any kind and what
that was like about all those times
where you didn't get on so well
yeah we have we we have had that
opportunity and again and it's been
nice and it's been uh i'm trying to i
think the word he used is cathartic yeah
and
but we have and it is and that's
again that's another thing that can fall
back into that romance where there's a
happy ending
to it all i mean some of what there are
times i look at my life in my career i
think holy cow i'm one big cliche why do
you feel like it's a cliche and sorry to
interrupt you oh no well because again
because it's been so i don't know it was
you know i was a very cliche
fame and fortune and drugs and alcohol
and almost falling apart and then oh the
good turnaround and the happy ending and
sounds like a disney movie show
so look don't i'm not complaining by any
stretch um but uh you know we have in
fact
we did it again at wrestlemania because
uh they were filming something for the
rivalries the amy rivalries that we did
um
and
you know brett and i have again even
being asked about it all the time as you
you know everyone does now they joke
about you know having to ask about that
incident but he and i are forever ever
linked in that respect um
and and again you go through sort of a
full
uh circle with that to where i don't
know up front you i don't know you enjoy
it and then you you hate it and then you
enjoy it again then you understand it
then you have peace with it and yeah um
it's it's it's just quite the uh i don't
know evolution and learning process but
i wouldn't trade where brett and i are
at now
for anything in the world um and they
are they're it's always very pleasant
when we run across each other now um and
and again i always you know i'm always
you know
flattered i mean it's amazing he'll you
know he'll remember you know my you know
me and my wife's anniversary and stuff
like that and yeah
and even on my birthday and stuff like
that and so it's it's just fantastic to
be where we're at now with one another
yeah and uh one of the biggest sort of
wrestlemania of all time in my opinion
anyway was when we had mike tyson
special guest referee ewing stone cold
steve austin mike tyson joins d
generation x it was so entertaining like
it though you were the
the best bastard possible like you you
got under his skin
um and and also i felt like you brought
an edge to your character specifically
for stone cold like it you you turned on
the sort of nastiness and the tough guy
that sean michaels could be
um but what i didn't realize until i
started looking into it more was that
you were dealing with a bit of a back
injury it wasn't necessarily an easy
time for you
i would never have known at the time but
what was that whole thing like of
working with mike and stonecall being at
his white hot best
uh and then handing the belt over
everything with working with mike was
fantastic i mean he was he was he was
great the entire time
uh look and as i will
as much as i'd love to think i was just
a fantastic actor um i think probably
so much of that turning it up is because
at that time i was i was real life
pissed angry hurt you know what i mean
ev all the all the uh ingredients one
needs to portray be a nasty meme
i was i was real life all of it um but i
did i i freely brought that you know uh
to television and i do i think i think
that it worked i guess they go back
that's why i always say like i would
love to have not
gone through all of that stuff and made
everybody suffer through it but i'm not
sure if my work would have been what it
was you know um
so
i will say it was tough at the time
going through it i look back on it um
i'll say this for a dude that was on one
hand
probably you know
like in a fight it's not like you're
going to bet on me every time but i will
say as far as enduring pain and during
injury
and things like that i was pretty tough
uh
i certainly had help at the time but um
you know i always went out there and
tried to
give the best i could
um that whole that whole situation um
you know was fantastic for the time i
think i was
doing
some really good work at that time as
you said steve was white hot
tyson
was giving us some unbelievable
crossover
press that we've never had
um
and and again i recognized not the best
situation for everybody by any stretch
um
but
for the time i think i was the perfect
guy
uh you know the most hated guy we could
get to have steve conker uh to be the
guy that was going to carry the company
into the future
yeah and i mean steve uh
fellow uh texan uh
as well you you you king made him you
know you you
it wouldn't have been right for it to be
with someone else i don't feel like
because
he needed a worthy opponent and you
brought that and more and you never knew
whether or not he was you were going to
slip out and and riddle away from him
and make him you know wait for his day
um what was it like seeing steve take
the company to new heights in that
period
well and that's the thing i thought to
me
i didn't know
so you knew it was big but i didn't i
don't know i just don't know that
anybody was prepared
again if they were god bless them but i
don't know if anybody was prepared
for i don't know the enormity of what
steve would go on to produce from a
company standpoint um
it just it was amazing and it caught
fire um
again i i just all i can say is for
somebody to sat home and watched it it
was one of the most amazing things and
incredibly joyful to watch i get it i
got to be honest i thought they did
fantastic stuff again not just with
steve but with everybody what a roster
if you go back and you look at that
roster at the time
steve was fantastic but he really did
have some great support as well um and
and that is when uh top to bottom the
wwe uh talent pool was pretty stout
when you had your last match against the
undertaker and i know undertaker thought
so highly of the work you guys did
together
how did it feel when you were in the
ring
and the match was over and you were
getting that ovation and you just got to
have that moment of
okay this is it now
it was nice to be perfectly honest it
was it was really nice um
look i as i mentioned to people i i felt
that after the first one i felt a piece
that i hadn't felt before
after a match and that just
got me thinking that okay i'm
it is because i'd already been thinking
about it and i felt that i'm i'm ready
i'm ready for this to be the end um
and
after the last one there really is
there's a piece that settles in
um
because i'm not sure people certainly
and i can't speak for everybody else i
don't know if everybody understands
certainly for me anyway the the
i don't want to say stress but the
anxiety the mental kind of focus that
wrestlemania took on me anyway every
year and and also
they say not just wrestlemania but i was
like that about
most pay-per-views most of my matches
and then wrestlemania was just
all together a different
mental frame of mind that i tried to get
myself to
um
every year
and sometimes that can
be tiring and
so
to know that that was going to be the
last one there was a there was a big
sense of relief there um and again i was
also very proud of the body of work you
know i i felt like at that time there
wasn't anything left on the table and i
think for me that all those
things just made it so much easier for
me
uh to be content walking away when we
yeah when we look at your your body of
work there's so many great matches so
many great wrestlers i wondered
who your
favorite guys to work with
were just on a regular basis where you
just enjoy those matches whether we seen
them or not you know the the obvious
they're ones again like like hunter and
taker obviously are always in there
it's hard not to put scott hall in there
because scott and i could go i mean
scott and i worked with each other
seemed like every night for two and a
half years
and i don't know that we ever had to
give it any thought and the same with
hunter you know hunter and mark you know
i mean there were just times that we
could go out there i just had chemistry
with those guys in a way that
it was almost unfair how much you didn't
have to think about
what it was we were going to do because
there was just such a cohesiveness to
what we did
um but then other you know again i would
say i really enjoyed working with chris
you know uh jericho
enjoyed working with obviously kevin
[Music]
trying to think i mean jeff jared and i
had you know fun mick you know mick and
i didn't get to wrestle that many times
but it was always really easy with mick
as well he's somebody that didn't know
very well
um not like we hung out but every time
we got in the ring with each other it
was you know again one of those things
where you just had this chemistry with
the guy that you're like
this would be you know
easy to have a good storyline with him
you know
i don't know again kurt was fun kurt and
i didn't get to do a lot either um
but i don't know again there's just so
many guys and it's hard to
understand yeah
so many different reasons you and kurt
angle i remember that specifically being
a great
match to just watch and it is funny
because
i guess we're watching it from a fight
perspective where it's choreographed but
for you you these some of these guys
it's just like a dance partner it's just
like you you
you don't even need to call anything
it's just happening and
that's the easiest way to work for you
guys
for me and again i always i can remember
people like trying to describe my style
and i don't know that i really had one
i just so enjoyed adapting
to the style of all these other guys and
i think that's where i found
i don't know the most joy which is and
then again for me it's the most
challenging is can i adapt whatever it
is i do where i am
to
these guys strengths and i always had
the utmost confidence in all of them
um
you know whatever highlighting my
strengths again um
so i don't know i think i think for me
the variety of guys uh was enjoyable but
i also
had a great deal of admiration
for the ability of the guys
that i was in there with it feels like
the way you're describing this is sort
of like
you become almost like a swiss army
knife where you can
tailor your style to anything and that
was why you were able to get the best
out of so many different kinds of
wrestlers that you would be opposite
exactly i guess that's yeah and that's
why i said
if it sounds right but i just again you
know all these guys knew what they did
so well
and all they i knew they're like well
heck all i have to do is adapt and you
know what i mean and make what they do
look even better and you know and
because i
i always try to tell people i don't mean
it to be you know because again i break
you know i'll diminish my you know
you know my brand
but that's look i i didn't do that many
offensive moves um
you know i mean most of what i did and
of course look people now again because
i do interviews like this and i say
stuff like that people are like yeah he
wasn't as great as
you know
everybody thinks he is
like okay that's fine as well but
what i think what i did well which was
again which was adjust to everybody
and make everybody
perform at their best okay
i don't know i think that's what you
know i'll just say that's what i always
admire about you know michael jordan is
that he made everybody on his team
better and it didn't matter what kind of
defense he went up against he was going
to adjust to it and still score and that
is what greatness does
and that is why almost every wrestler
seems to say their favorite person to
wrestle with was you
because it wasn't like they had to
adjust you were allowing them to be the
best them and helping them along with
that and
this makes total sense now um but uh one
of my favorite eras uh one of my
favorite parts of wrestling is
degeneration x and obviously you were
the founding member you your humor
uh that boyish cheeky ridiculous humor
that you guys brought to the screens it
was yes stone cold was doing his thing
the rock was doing his thing but by god
did that make a huge difference to the
late 90s of wrestling and sway
everything back towards wa
how did you guys come up with a creative
for that and and and what was it like
for you guys doing that it was a blast
especially again
starting out when
you know there wasn't
we were the first ones kind of doing it
and we were there you know we were doing
attitude before it was called any of
that and we were doing reality tv before
it was called any of that um
what we did honestly is we just
um you know really put the gas on what i
had sort of been doing from a promo
standpoint out there anyway which was
as they call them work shoots saying a
lot of stuff that was real life true
that people didn't like in the back and
i was going out there and taking
advantage of a live microphone on live
television
um and then that's what 100 i started
doing
but we started at least tailoring it to
not so much
other talent specific
um but we would do it more towards i
don't know a generalized subject and
half of it had to do with our anatomy
which everybody thought
you know which everybody always thought
was funny um
was it but look we as we tell everybody
we got in a lot of trouble at first
before it got to be cool with everybody
yeah because i assume originally when
you're pushing buttons and you're seeing
a lot of these half truths and more than
that you're coming back and then you've
got to look these guys in the eye after
you've just said this stuff
was that
pretty heated
yeah no for sure well and again it was
like obviously everyone knows that was
you know
part of the reason for you know brett
and i but now hunter and i were doing it
more again from a fun standpoint but
there were still nuggets of truth there
that rubbed people a little bit the
wrong way and it was made them a little
uncomfortable plus they also felt that
we were pulling the curtain back a
little bit too much and
um that was just something that
from our standpoint
you know just philosophically we just
disagreed with you know you know we just
felt that
more people knew what the wwe was that
didn't um
and there were just a lot of people that
were steeped in the tradition
of of the wrestling business and we felt
that those times were changing um and
and anytime you anytime you ruffle the
feathers of tradition uh it gets ugly
fantastic i really appreciate you going
into that before before we go um there
is a huge
show coming to the uk
in september clash of uh at the castle
um
what are your thoughts on that it's
going to be massive yeah it is it's
going to be huge look i'm just thrilled
we're you know again when was the last
time we were there for some said
summerslam all those
years ago i'm thinking uh davey boy
smith versus brett i think it was right
yeah davey and brett yeah that's i
that's the thing i i
that's this is just
it's been a long time but there's been a
long time coming um because again and
this is not me blowing smoke but
from the first time back in that gosh i
want to say 89
or 90.
possibly yeah i mean when we first
started going over the uk
it was the first time i ever felt like i
mean like i can remember going like oh
my goodness i feel like one of the
beatles
it just was you know i love it
it was just just the it really is the
the appreciation the of the fans the
excitement the energy um that you all
brought to the shows was just off the
charts um and look even to this it's
like that to this day even for us the uk
brand you know i mean nxt uk
it's just a different environment um and
so
to be able to have this
on a wwe level at you know at a stadium
um to me
uh has got to be you know that's just
it's got to be crazy i think this is
going to be a fantastic show i think
it's something um i hope that begins a
new tradition of us being able to go
over there a lot more often and do some
more premium live events um or at least
bigger shows because again
um i will say like you all have just
been a just a fantastic market for us
for so long um
and i know everybody it was like that
when i did it and it's still like that
now the guys and the girls
love performing over there because again
every time you're out there you can feel
it and
um
that's why we do this you know i mean to
get out there and feel that visceral
connection uh between our performance
and the people and um
not many not many places you know again
love my country and everything but not
you know not many places uh bring that
um
like being over in the uk to be
perfectly honest so that's no
that's no blowing smoke that's that's
sincere uh
you know gratitude for what it is y'all
bring to our shows
well uh i'm being told it's time to wrap
up sean but the huge thank you for this
you are one of the greatest of all time
by anyone's you know judgment i mean
you've you've done amazing things
and uh thanks very much i really
appreciate the time
yeah no i appreciate you having me and
thanks for giving me the time thanks
very much that was sean michaels the
heartbreak kid on the true jordi podcast